à Dublin.
(Rires)
Mais elle est en bonne voie.
Voici la dernière partie.
Sur notre prétendue arrivée au bout de tous nos efforts.
À Saint-Jacques –
que ce soit Saint-Jacques
ou la Mecque
ou encore Bénarès
ou Kyoto
ou ce seuil que vous vous êtes fixé,
l'approche perturbante pour réaliser tous vos objectifs.
Une des difficultés pour avancer dans sa vie,
pour entrer dans ce corps,
et ce monde complètement,
c'est quand on commence à réaliser
qu'on a produit trois illusions irréductibles
que le reste du monde a partagées avec vous depuis toujours.
La première illusion, c'est de pouvoir construire tant bien que mal une vie
dans laquelle on n’est pas vulnérable.
En quelque sorte de pouvoir être immunisé contre toutes les difficultés,
la maladie et la mort
auxquelles l’humanité est soumise depuis la nuit des temps.
Si on regarde la nature,
il n’y a rien dans ce monde
qui ne soit soumis à des cycles, avec, d'abord, une naissance
ou une dissimulation,
et ensuite une croissance, une plénitude,
puis un beau début de disparition,
et enfin une disparition complète plus austère.
On observe la vie et on dit : « C’est beau,
mais pourrais-je avoir seulement la première moitié de l’équation ?
Quand ma disparition se produira,
je fermerai les yeux et j'attendrai le prochain cycle. »
Ce qui veut dire que la plupart des humains font la guerre à la réalité,
50% du temps.
La personne mature
est capable de vivre le cycle entier.
La seconde illusion est
de pouvoir construire une vie où son cœur ne soit pas brisé.
L’amour est le premier domaine où on l'applique.
Au début d’une nouvelle histoire d’amour ou d'un nouveau mariage,
on pense avoir trouvé la personne qui ne nous brisera pas le cœur.
Je suis désolé, mais,
inconsciemment, on choisit cette personne pour sa capacité à le faire.
(Rires)
Elle vous brisera le cœur.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que vous tenez à elle.
Vous pensez aux parents, n’est-ce pas ?
Les parents pensent qu'ils seront un père ou une mère parfait.
Vos enfants vous briseront le cœur.
Ils n’ont même pas besoin de faire quelque chose d'incroyable.
Même si souvent, c'est ce qu’ils font –
(Rires)
pour vous briser le cœur.
Ils vivent avec vous des années comme des espions, des saboteurs,
observant toutes vos réactions psychologiques,
et détectant chacune de vos faiblesses.
Et un jour,
lorsqu’ils ont environ 14 ans,
quand vous avez le dos tourné,
dans la cuisine,
que vous préparez quelque chose pour eux –
(Rires)
le poignard psychologique vous transperce.
(Applaudissements)
Et vous vous demandez comment ils ont su où frapper précisément.
(Rires)
Ils répondent :
« Je t’ai observé pendant
(Rires)
au moins plusieurs années. »
On espère aussi se blinder avec nos parcours professionnels
pour éviter d’avoir le cœur brisé au travail.
Mais, si on est honnête dans son travail,
on aura le cœur brisé.
On devra arriver à une limite
où on ne sait plus comment faire.
On ne sait plus comment aller d'un point A à un point B.
Quel est le résultat ?
On se retrouve dans une relation plus fidèle avec la réalité.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'il faut demander de l’aide.
Peine de cœur.
On ne choisit pas d'avoir une peine de cœur,
on a seulement le choix d’avoir le cœur brisé
pour des gens, des choses et des projets qui nous tiennent profondément à cœur.
La dernière illusion, c'est
de pouvoir tant bien que mal planifier suffisamment et faire en sorte
de pouvoir voir la lumière au bout du tunnel,
exactement de là où on se trouve,
tout droit vers l’horizon.
Quand on y réfléchit,
le seul environnement où ça pourrait arriver
serait un désert plat,
vidé de toute autre forme de vie.
Mais, même dans un désert plat,
la courbure de la terre gênerait pour voir le chemin.
Donc, non,
on voit le chemin,
puis il disparaît,
et on le voit réapparaître à nouveau.
Le chemin de Saint-Jacques est ainsi fait,
l'arrivée supposée,
qui est, en même temps, une sorte de retour au point de départ.
On a tous connaissance de ce voyage,
présent dans toutes nos belles traditions spirituelles :
le pèlerinage.
Mais, juste en se tenant debout, appuyé sur la réalité de sa vie,
sans essayer de s'en abstraire dans un futur stratégique,
qui n’est en fait qu'une façon de fuir une peine de cœur actuelle,
la capacité à être debout, appuyé sur la réalité de sa vie,
et de regarder l’horizon qui nous attire –
à ce moment-là,
on est le chemin tout entier.
On est la conversation toute entière.
« Saint-Jacques. »
« La route visible, puis invisible
la route visible, puis invisible
le flanc de la colline dissimulant puis révélant le chemin à prendre
la route s'éloignant de toi
comme si elle te laissait marcher sur de l'air,
avant de te rattraper,
de te rattraper,
te retenir quand tu pensais tomber,
te rattraper,
et la voie à suivre,
la voie à suivre, toujours à la fin,
le chemin par où tu es venu,
le chemin que tu as suivi, le chemin qui t'a porté vers ton futur,
qui t'a mené jusqu'ici,
peu importe qu'il t'ait parfois volé tes promesses,
peu importe qu'il ait toujours dû te briser le cœur tout au long du chemin :
le sentiment
le sentiment de devoir partir du plus profond de toi
vers la révélation,
d'avoir risqué ta vie
pour quelque chose qui semble être tant à l'intérieur de toi que loin devant toi
et qui te rappelle finalement
vers la seule route que tu peux suivre,
marcher comme tu l'as fait, dans tes guenilles d'amour
et parler d'une voix qui, la nuit, devient une prière pour arriver sain et sauf,
pour qu'un jour,
un jour, tu réalises
que ce que tu voulais est finalement déjà arrivé
qu'un jour, tu réalises
il y a fort longtemps
dans la maison où tu as vécu avant de commencer
et que
et qu'à chaque pas en chemin,
tu as porté le cœur, l'esprit et la promesse
qui t'ont d'abord fait partir avant de puiser en toi
et que
et que tu étais plus merveilleux
en souhaitant simplement trouver un chemin
tu étais plus merveilleux en souhaitant simplement trouver un chemin
que les toits dorés de chaque destination que tu aies atteinte
que les toits dorés de chaque destination que tu aies atteinte :
comme si, tout du long,
tu avais pensé que l'arrivée serait une ville aux dômes dorés,
avec des foules t'acclamant,
et en prenant le virage
que tu imaginais être la fin de la route,
tu avais juste trouvé une simple reflet
et, sous ce visage tourné vers l'arrière, une révélation claire
et une autre invitation,
tout cela en un clin d’œil,
tout cela en un clin d’œil :
comme une personne
comme une personne ou un endroit que tu as toujours cherché
comme un audacieux terrain de liberté qui t'appelle au loin,
comme une autre vie
comme une autre vie,
et la route
la route continue de s'étirer devant toi. »
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Merci beaucoup. Merci.
Vous êtes très aimables. Merci.
(Applaudissements)